right so this movie deals with the
answer to nine-tenths of the world's
questions porn Don Jon so Don Jon is the
directorial debut of Joseph
gordon-levitt Joseph gordon-levitt's the
main star he plays a guy who watches
absurd amounts of porn every day and
then starts dating Scarlett Johansson
let me rephrase that he plays a guy
who's an average normal everyday dude
who starts dating Scarlett Johansson and
of course she ain't diggin the porn so
he hides the porn from her but he still
watches the born and they here's a
dating movie I would call it a romantic
comedy it's not as comedic as it is
dramatic it's a dramedy it's a dramedy
about a guy who watches a lot of porn
the funny thing about it is just how
real it is I just have girl to Levitz
going on this whole tangent about how
porn is better than real sex he just
starts breaking it down I feel bad for
all the dudes we're gonna watch this
with their chicks and they're just gonna
be like he's not and you gotta give the
movie props for its relevance like the
number one thing that I've noticed that
relationshipy people start fighting
about is porn which I've just never
understood that [ __ ] I haven't women are
reading Fifty Shades of Grey I don't
like Airborne's disgusting engine
[ __ ] I've literally known of women
who were reading Fifty Shades of Grey
who are just yelling at their dude for
watching porn I'm like you're reading
boy it's the same ooh don't want to be
sexist so both sides of it or do to
watch porn who hate the fact that their
chicks meet vibrators and dildos that do
this [ __ ] this movie deals with all that
[ __ ] that's why I mention it here is
because it is relevant for the movie and
I like seeing that what I really like
seeing is the fact that Joseph
gordon-levitt this is his directorial
debut it's really good the dude is a
bright future ahead of him that's all
I'm saying
he's just really stylish time-lapses in
a couple of scenes that was really cool
he's a master at showing clips of porn
that are actually it doesn't it doesn't
show the porn --is-- things happening he
just shows the chicks faces or it just
cuts off that to me is really talented
when you can make porn rated-r it's just
good job JGL I will say not all the
characters are relevant in this movie he
has a sister 98% of the time you see her
in this movie she's texting one thing a
dialogue she raises her head in one part
to say one thing maybe they were going
for
it was like yeah but when she does say
that one thing it's gonna make it more
relevant because it's the thing that she
felt that she needed to say but really I
was just like why is that character in
here I don't get I don't know why she's
here but in the end Joseph gordon-levitt
was really good in the movie Scarlett
Johansson was really good in the movie
everyone in the movie was really good in
the movie the movie was well directed it
was a bit short I'm not gonna lie the
movie just ended it cut off and I was
like I guess that's the end of our movie
but the movie was enjoyable it's
relevant subject matter if a couple has
the you watch porn and I hated argument
they should watch this movie I will say
Don John is a very high goodtime no
alcohol required I've wanted to say buy
it on blu-ray it's like one tear under
point is is worth watching I had a good
time at the movie great directorial
debut from Joseph gordon-levitt good job
JGL we love you still bright so Don John
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more